like he's been doing this quite a bit
just ignoring the ignoring the
semitarish uh options with Knight takes
D5 going midi 5 going which B7 uh E3 and
uh opting for various uh playable setups
here with black but today he does
something that that obviously looks a
bit gambly
Bishop G4 because you get the feeling
that if I play screen B3 black is about
to start punching stuff right I think
you play 9 bg7 and you just kind of
ignore both D5 and B7 and say yeah show
me that was I guess what he is doing
here is he's saying uh if I change the
bishop away
it might go to F5 and I don't like it
going back to F5 it's a good Square so I
will play Queen A4 check which does look
very odd absolutely forces well not
forces but very much provokes black to
places 76 which is the move they want to
play
but now I will be able to take control
of this diagonal which is very often uh
the most important diagonal that is very
heavily contested and sort of the old
thinking about the Carlsbad structures
was very much
uh if white controls this diagonal and
the black Bishop gets stuck on C8
doesn't get traded for anything why does
it have been better and if you do at
some point get to play which by five
which takes you three uh black
immediately equalizes so
he is very much engaged in the fight for
the control
over the F5 Square yeah this is I think
the biggest story of the game so far
Magnus played what is a very very rare
choice and move seven in a very very
well known position
this is now move 11. Magnus is down half
an hour and Perham somehow managed to
spend a full hour
from move eight until move 11 so that's
foremost in a row yeah there it is I'm
happy I got it in 10 seconds 10 seconds
before Magnus actually played that boat
this comes with a lot of risk attached
though absolutely it's not just upon
sacrifice potentially but
strategically C5 yeah so it's question
marks I think so yeah it must be just
either immediately or we throw in like
six and then we go G4
you know I've yeah let's look at this
looks like one of those Quincy two
nimsos now no but that actually is quite
Pleasant for white right we just slicing
oh sorry I forgot yeah just just blanked
on the fact that there's a
I'm quite liking it and G4 played by
Parham immediately immediately yeah so I
guess he was expecting C5 and he's in no
mood to
back down you know bail out siren on his
mind yeah
and the question here for Magnus is
Bishop G6 or take on C4 on deforcer uh
first kind of a nice backup land Magnus
takes on default instantly so it feels
like they've both been burning their
time to calculate their specific
operation uh but as you say instead of
Knight hd4 okay it's probably playable
there but even if just Knight C6 yeah
exactly I felt like we we have very
decent long-term compensation if we just
continue playing
I guess Knight G2 and we want to try and
castle castle King side and stabilize
with this position why there's just a
lot better coordinated
is a lot closer
to completing development and so on and
also we have sort of ruled out Knight
takes G4 because after 90 Focus p7 this
is no longer a check yeah I don't know
if if this is immediately refuted but it
feels like a worse version of the same
right just straight up worse version
because the screen is so strong and so
difficult to challenge that
you know you Quincy it might be your
best choice here or something yeah and
uh and then why aren't we swapping or
swapping those off the board earlier
and I don't see any way to justify like
some sacrifices
brokerage forever although you'll have
to go Knight
or probably this I I assume this also
wins but it looks a bit messy magnus's
game after Queen F6 uh Parham did take
some time trying to find you know
anything playable that isn't Queen takes
F6 did not succeed
and I very much like that he's a
decision to play Rook Divine and not
long castles because the very important
difference is
F2 is just not hanging like if you if
you do the same as you would there
uh the fact that F2 is not hanging here
allows us
a lot more uh leeway feels the king is
actually going to be pretty useful early
to win some lines I guess you can play
Maybe
Rook G3 Rook H3 Maybe
yeah
um yeah and I think before we can go G5
we're still a lot better but I think we
are making a draw here a lot more
comfortably than we would have done with
the King on C1 because we never have to
worry about from df8 which is good key
to in response we just have better
connectivity between our pieces compared
to those other lines we're still not
fighting for any advantage at all Magnus
decides to throw in rookie a check
surprises me a little bit this has to
have some kind of an immediate
explanation I think it's similar to that
last variation maybe the idea is just
rookie four just to Hoover up some
points just start attacking it
immediately yeah yeah that's a good
point that is a very good point that's
the only explanation for rookie eight I
guess otherwise uh we're gonna go for
the Deep one all together quite happy
about it yeah White's Kings because yeah
our guys are just much more active and
the King on D4 is just going to be so
much more of a of a factor than the King
on G8 how about if I push the other Pawn
the one on B2 yeah uh no this is I'm
pretty sure it's completely fine for
black but it doesn't really feel all
that disastrous for white either
feels quite playable trade very highly
my cheap looking G3 doesn't look right
and Bishop takes B2 for instance you
give white time to play G5 Rook F4 I
know before
so I can play
and I take on Chief and your take on G5
and The Rook H1 you have G6 yeah
suddenly this actually does start
looking like a runeville a little bit as
Marcus often does just very much
enjoying himself on the clock 55 against
16 here move 23. the position shouldn't
be very complicated but it still might
matter it might start measuring the uh
the clock advantage that he has you can
definitely see it uh playing an actual
role in the game gave it some thought
left himself 12 minutes and played D6
yeah to which Magnus replied by
instantly swapping the knights off the
board
and
I am assuming taking on G4
and there we go taking a G4 has happened
and D7 is just very well met by well
Jeff I think okay you're flicking the
check first
yeah I think I can be greedy I think I
can pick up on B2 and then do whatever I
please yeah because it's very important
that you you can't move forward like I'm
using this exact moment to force you on
the back rank take on bitsu and
yeah the set file I don't really care
about doing it all that much yeah I like
Rook D5 I think it's a very logical move
because he wants to be able to play King
D3
and for the polony six still to be
supported yeah Magnus goes Rook D7
hinging once again in the very very
strong plan of bringing the king over
Rooker fund attempts to stop that by
introducing the age of 95 check
the model just calmly picks up this
bottom bit soon while also
may be introducing the third rule G63
although that probably doesn't work just
yet
seven and try to ah but yeah this is
just fast enough right I just gotta come
to E6 and then I think it's just fast
enough perhaps played Rook D3 and
apparently the engine absolutely hates
it yeah
okay forcing me back
right was my point but maybe you can
play King F1 here and the bishop doesn't
have ah yeah and you you get the player
Vegeta that's sneaky
and this is turned him well I say time
but it's been going in magnus's
direction for a while it's just so hard
to play polite yeah and he plays Bishop
F6 very quickly which
uh supposedly is not the best but still
pretty good
Rook A4 looks like it's not going
anywhere anytime soon yeah it is a very
logical move the bishop sort of belongs
there Bishop 3 wasn't that required but
confused as to what he's supposed to try
to achieve here because last three moves
were Rook H1 F1 and then he spent
a full two Tempe moving The Rook back
and forth from D3 to G5 questioning him
the Beats upon and the move now this was
now to be
probably just waiting for black why why
now now I like I for the first time in
this tournament really and this is such
a weird spot for me to become suddenly
interested I wish I had some some way to
contact Fiona in time Chad was very
impressed with Magnus blitzing out king
of seven but no no Rook before was a
difficult move king of seven really
wasn't the moment I I kept on saying the
woman abundantly have filed the king
always comes to E6 yeah this was not
tricky he set that up with the root D7
like five moves ago yeah the trick was
to see uh to see the the point of
keeping the Rook on the B file not the a
file because after Rook takes A3 yeah
he'll have
extra extra couple outside passers on
both a B and G and the H like one one of
them gets dropped but
I think it's completely winning I don't
think
they worry very much about converting
this
yeah 94 and then I mean whatever you
please yeah okay three played Magnus
agrees with us I do wonder whether
playing it with like A6 or B6 or
something was that's probably also
pretty good yeah white seems completely
completely uh stymied yeah yeah but no
no real need not to not to cash in like
whichever whichever way you want this is
completely winning yeah Magnus will win
this in his sleep yeah creating those
imbalances in Parham he's down to a
couple of seconds yeah at least he'll
make me 40 most likely but yeah he'll
he'll he'll get to 40 here because his
moves are uh easy and also entirely
irrelevant like I want to say that they
bear no weight anymore three down with
no passers no counter play Black about
to start pushing
not a ton of hope I wonder like in terms
of clean cleanliness here do we go
language B5 here no I'm gonna smug
that's not interested
snaps on B6 yeah why not why not yeah
it's pawns roll very quickly actually
um yeah white spawns are never going
anywhere
94 it's King C6 the only Square no but
like once again I don't think we need to
really want to trust this you know I
assume it's meaning like I assume this
position is
still completely winning for black
but I see absolutely no reason to
be one up and we can be too up
yeah you can see six looks
okay he's gone forward King do you think
yeah that's very similar yeah
very similar to what we're discussing I
think we're so far offended that I would
actually give up H6 yeah and win this
pretty yeah King C4 electric H5 we go B5
Rook H6 Rook uh
this is the only question right to maybe
just wrote These yeah but only four
right but I guess we're still away like
no hang on this this yeah you don't yeah
this I've drawn maybe not drawn but I've
allowed a bit too much like there's no
way we need to allow this much even if
it's still winning yeah
seven because I don't want the king to
cross oh wait same thing yeah yeah it is
I'm very confused by wiper I'm chose to
play Rooker 5 here I think
although he didn't like Rook H7 actually
maybe his point is if he goes Rooker
five the solution is just Rook F7
and then Rook H5 Rook H7 and we push the
outside to yeah and otherwise and
otherwise the B the V Pawn just gets to
be three and then black wins on the
king's side maybe he wants to give a
check
and then go away back to F5 but yeah
it's probably losing slower than the
previous line but that's about as good
as you can yeah I see that pawn it
doesn't even drop off yeah yeah like you
you can't you can't take much examples
yeah
rookie six played and it's also move 40
so Perham will now spend some time
considering whether he needs to play on
from here they both of course know what
the result is but yeah I guess there's
no carb as long as he doesn't like think
for 35 minutes here with white yeah like
we know how this movie ends yes
final stages we absolutely do know how
this movie ends yeah he very rarely
tanks after me fully thinking about that
good cash game when he was maybe winning
and he didn't even pause there so why
pause now against Madness I think I
think the point will be on between like
30 seconds
I think the year 25 B2 and maybe he
resigns there because he actually I
think loses the g-pawn without even
being able to get
screen doesn't look like there's much
play left in it you can tell a magnus's
uh body language he's ready ready to get
out of there
B3 why even look at anything else at
this point yeah honestly if you play
rookie 6 here and allow King D3 you also
have to question how easy this is like
legitimately you might still be winning
after King A4 but considering it's the B
Pawn specifically yeah but he has played
King A4 okay I guess still still fine
and that's the only Pawn this is me this
is true about E5 played I don't know how
could have waited for a movement
I guess he's also very done with this
game yeah
what waiting moves sweater oh the king
E3 whatever okay I mean this mission is
no better and no worse than the previous
one and E5 kind of makes you lose faster
I think describing it as some kind of
weird tilt is
not unreasonable yeah
I mean if you can ask anyone end game
questions like basic one-on-one end
games is the guy to ask but yeah
you know and once again we come back to
this discussion that also you know as
long as he doesn't thank it doesn't
really waste anybody's time too much
but yeah I think like his expected value
there is precisely zero I guess you play
Magnus 100 times in this position
precise to zero sort of regardless of
like what time of the day it is like
what Magnus has been doing prior to
being asked this question or like it's
just there are no sets of circumstances
which result in this
actually not losing him the game yeah so
it looks like well there's two ways to
win this either you play over K5 and you
get your king out so if white stops
that with Rook A8 then um yeah
the exact mechanism that we were showing
The Rook is already on the fifth which
is quite useful and in this position
without the bottom of three and the
bottom left six the threats will be four
before very simply
thingy three Rook G1 is quite
straightforward actually no not here
yeah here we get checked so copy King E3
give a check first yeah we give a check
and then we go either e4b4 or rookie one
yeah and
you know otherwise
otherwise if your player will see a
check you're listening before and would
be five yeah Magnus not hiding his
feelings here he knows uh this one's
gone on longer than it needed to yeah
he's I guess he is a bit miffed that he
is being actually questioned about this
it's probably been 20 years since he's
been asked this question yeah and there
we go if we do finally see a handshake
her hand resigns